Most actors will eventually find themselves
locking lips with another actor who, in real life,
has nothing to do with them romantically.
Sometimes, these kisses have little to
no consequences. But other times, onscreen
kisses can get actors in trouble in real life.
In 1995, Star Trek: Deep Space
Nine aired what proved to be
one of the most controversial
episodes of the entire franchise.
Jadzia Dax takes center stage in season 4's
"Rejoined," where she's reunited with Lenara Kahn.
Dax and Lenara are "joined Trill," who share
their existence with slug-like symbionts that
carry their memories and experiences from
host to host over the course of centuries.
With their respective previous hosts, Dax
and Lenara were once married. However,
it's forbidden for "joined Trill" to become
involved with romantic partners from previous
lifetimes. So, when they kiss,
it definitely has consequences.
This happened to be the case in the
real world as well. Dax actress Terry
Farrell and the makers of DS9 faced a lot
of backlash for the kiss. In the Star Trek:
Deep Space Nine Companion book, producer Ronald D.
Moore said one of their southern affiliates took
the show off the air while another producer,
Steve Oster, said he received plenty
of calls complaining about the episode.
In the 2018 documentary What We Left Behind,
Farrell seems more than content with
her part in the episode, saying:
"Still to this day, people come
up to me and say, 'Thank you.'"
Sadie Sink entered the cast of Stranger
Things in the show's second season as Max,
eventually becoming part of the team of young
heroes investigating all the crazy stuff going
on in Hawkins, Indiana. While Dustin holds
a torch for Max for most of the season,
it's Lucas who shares a first kiss with her
in that season's finale. On the face of it,
there didn't appear to be anything particularly
controversial about the kiss, but that changed
once enough fans caught an episode of the
aftershow series, Beyond Stranger Things.
There, Sink revealed her kiss with Lucas wasn't
originally in the script, and she didn't know
about it until the day the scene was filmed.
Ross Duffer, one of Stranger Things' showrunners,
apparently jokingly told Sink that it was
her fault the kiss was added. Duffer had
previously chided Sink about having her kiss
Lucas, and according to Sink, Duffer said the
fact that she was, quote, "so freaked out" by
the idea is what inspired him to add the scene.
"You reacted so strongly to this. I was just
joking. You were so freaked out that I was like,
"Well, I gotta make her do it now!"
A lot of fans expressed rage over the story,
due in no small part to it coming to light
around the same time as the #MeToo movement.
In the wake of the controversy, Sink
backtracked a bit, telling TheWrap:
"I mean, of course I was nervous [...] But I never
objected to [it] or felt pushed into anything."
Billy Bob Thornton and Aneglina Jolie met in
1999 on the set of the dramedy Pushing Tin.
In spite of a 20-year age difference, they
married in 2000. However, their marriage ended
with divorce in 2003. According to Thornton,
the main reason they ultimately didn't work as
a couple was their different lifestyles.
In 2018, he told HFPA in Conversation:
"Hers is a global lifestyle, and
mine is an agoraphobic lifestyle. So,
that's really — that's the only reason
we're probably not still together."
Besides this, Thornton said one of the
more memorable stresses on the marriage
was his explicit scene with Halle Berry
in the 2001 romantic drama Monster's Ball.
Thornton explained to Speaking to The Sun
how filming Monster's Ball made things tough:
"She is one of the most beautiful women in the
world, and I am talking on the phone to my wife,
and she says, 'What have you been doing today?'
[...] Other people's situations are hard,
with areas of doubt. But if you are a
thousand miles from home on a film set
simulating sex with a beautiful
woman, it's even tougher."
Decades after its 1971 release, the dark
comedy Harold and Maude is considered
a classic. But the film wasn't so
well-regarded when it hit theaters,
and it helped steer the career trajectory
of its male lead to unwanted destinations.
Harold and Maude is about a death-obsessed
man in his early 20s who drives a hearse,
stages bizarre fake suicides for fun,
and regularly attends the funerals of
people he's never met. It's at one of these
funerals that Harold meets the elderly Maude,
who likewise goes to funeral services as
a hobby. The two become lovers — a notion
that didn't sit well with audiences. The
Guardian reported that Charles Mulvehill,
one of the film's producers, told Peter Biskind
that no one wanted to see these characters kiss:
"You couldn't drag people in. The
idea of a 20-year-old boy with an
80-year-old woman just made people want to vomit."
Bud Cort said kissing Ruth Gordon
on the screen was both, quote,
"a blessing and a curse." Professionally
speaking, he was typecast right away and
only offered what he called "weirdo" roles.
He turned them all down, including the role
of Billy Bibbit — ultimately played by Brad
Dourif — in One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest.
On the other hand, Cort expressed pride in
helping bring Harold and Maude to life. He
told The Guardian he made lasting friendships
on the set of the film, including with Gordon.
In How I Met Your Mother, Jason
Segel got in trouble for kissing
co-star Alyson Hannigan — who played
his wife, Lily — for two reasons.
First, because kissing him bothered Hannigan,
and second, because it put him in debt to her.
Segel was a smoker when the show began production,
and Hannigan isn't a fan of kissing
smokers. She told Digital Spy in 2008:
"I cannot stand cigarette smoke."
She said kissing Segel was, quote,
"like kissing an ashtray", clarifying that he
did use things such as mints to mask the taste.
Hannigan explained that Segel tried to use
her distaste of smoking as motivation to quit:
"When we started the pilot [for How I Met Your
Mother], he was like, 'Get me to stop smoking,
I'll be your best friend.' So we did
this bet where he would owe me $10
every time he had a cigarette. After
the first day, he owed me $200."
Hannigan recalls that Segel succeeded
in giving up cigarettes for a while,
but that he started smoking
again when under stress.
Thankfully, it doesn't seem like the butts
stopped the pair from remaining friends.
When they appeared together on the The Talk during
the lead up to the How I Met Your Mother finale,
Hannigan openly wept at the idea
of not working with Segel anymore.
Tommy Davidson claimed in his 2020 memoir
Living in Color: What's Funny About Me
that kissing Jada Pinkett Smith while
filming the 1999 romantic comedy Woo
almost got him into a fistfight
with her husband, Will Smith.
According to his memoir, neither he nor his
co-star were happy with how the film ended.
So, Davidson said he pitched the idea that
actually wound up being the film's finale,
with him and Jada Pinkett Smith dancing
in the middle of a city street. But while
Davidson and Smith had agreed on the new
ending, Davidson added something without
letting Jada know first. When they filmed the
scene, Davidson kissed her without warning.
Davidson says as soon as
the scene was done filming,
an enraged Will Smith followed him into his
trailer, where things nearly got violent:
"If a black man get mad at you from Philly,
and come at you, you best be ready."
Thankfully for everyone involved, the actress
stepped in and calmed things down between her
husband and her co-star. Davidson says that
he and Smith remain good friends to this day.
William Shatner doesn't enjoy the best reputation
in terms of how he treats his co-stars,
but there's at least one scene in Star Trek: The
Original Series that Shatner, Nichelle Nichols,
and anyone else involved should be proud of,
no matter what former colleagues say of them.
In the 1968 Star Trek episode "Plato's
Stepchildren" — airing only a year
after the U.S. Supreme Court deemed interracial
marriage legal — Shatner and Nichols treated
audiences to the first kiss between black and
white actors on scripted TV. In the scene,
Shatner's Captain Kirk and Nichols'
Lt. Uhura are forced to kiss each
other by a group of aliens who style
themselves after the ancient Greeks.
In her 1994 memoir, Beyond Uhura, Nichols wrote
that NBC wasn't happy when they learned of the
kissing scene, and a deal was struck between the
network and Star Trek's producers that two scenes
would be filmed — one in which Kirk and Uhura
kiss and one in which they didn't. Not wanting
the kiss-less scene to air, Shatner and Nichols
purposely bungled them so they wouldn't be usable.
While NBC was worried the episode wouldn't
play well in the South, Nichols, Shatner and
the rest of the cast and crew were disappointed
by a very different locale's reaction. "Plato's
Stepchildren" joined a list of four Star Trek: The
Original Series episodes the BBC refused to air
until 1994. The British broadcaster's official
reason for banning the episode, however,
was the sadism displayed by the episode's
villains rather than the interracial kiss.
In season 3 of the crime anthology series Fargo,
Ewan McGregor pulls double duty as twin brothers
Emmit and Ray Stussy. Emmit is a successful
businessman, and Ray is a down-on-his-luck parole
officer. The conflict between the brothers gets
heated after Ray falls for one of his parolees,
Nikki -- played by Mary Elizabeth Winstead.
She convinces Ray that his brother owes him
more than he's given. At first, you might
get the impression Nikki is using Ray
for her own benefit, but it soon becomes
clear her feelings for him are genuine.
It apparently wasn't too difficult for Winstead to
act like she loved Ray Stussy because it wouldn't
be too long before McGregor and Winstead
would become a couple -- in spite of both
being married when they met on the set. While
we don't know exactly when their relationship
started, it seems clear that working together on
Fargo had something to do with it. In May 2017,
a month after Fargo's season 3 finale, Winstead
announced her break-up with husband Riley Stearns.
And early in 2018, McGregor filed for
divorce from his wife of 22 years.
After McGregor and Winstead were spotted
kissing in public, People claimed that an
unnamed source said the pair had been
involved since Winstead's separation.
In November 2017, Star Trek: Discovery
featured the first kiss between two men
in the franchise. In the episode "Into
the Forest I Go," Paul Stamets nearly
dies when he uses his body to perform 133
consecutive warps with Discovery's spore drive
in order to give the crew the edge they need
over the Klingon's ship, the Sarcophagus.
"If we can save Pahvo, defeat the Klingons
and do all this, 133 jumps it is."
After the battle is won, Stamets agrees
to one more jump to a Federation starbase.
On his way to make the jump, he finds his
husband, Dr. Hugh Culber, and gives him
a loving kiss before assuring him that after
he's done, they'll be taking a long vacation.
Actors Wilson Cruz and Anthony Rapp predictably
faced a backlash from part of the audience.
In an eloquent and cutting Facebook post, Cruz
let those fans know he wasn't going
to be made to feel guilty for a kiss:
"I'm not here for your comfort.
That's not why we are here.
We're here to grow. Star Trek is and
has always been here to challenge
you to look outside of yourself and to see
other people and other experiences in yourself."
In at least one case, it wasn't
so much an onscreen kiss that got
an actor in trouble as much as it was an
avoided kiss that helped to tank a movie.
In spite of superstars Johnny Depp and Angelina
Jolie in the lead roles for the 2010 romantic
thriller The Tourist, critics panned the
flick. One of the more recurring criticisms
leveled against the film is the lack of
chemistry between its romantic leads,
including kissing scenes that failed
to excite anyone. A story that leaked
about a month before The Tourist's release
may provide a hint as to what went wrong.
In November 2010, the Daily Mail reported
that audiences would be cheated out of a
steamy shower scene between Depp and
Jolie. According to their source,
when Depp's longtime girlfriend, Vanessa
Paradis, learned of the sequence,
she reportedly begged Depp to pull out of
the film. Depp refused to quit the movie,
but he gave Paradis the concession that he
would demand the shower scene be scrapped.
It's only speculation, but considering what Depp
was willing to do to placate Paradis' jealousy,
it doesn't feel like a stretch
to wonder whether or not this
impacted his overall performance in the film.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.